you've lived your whole life being mute
and deaf and on top of it you're
pathetically weak and now you're going
to be forced to go to the depths of Hell
In order to save a kingdom that doesn't
want you to become the one true king I'm
going to break down the mistakes made
what you should do and how to beat the
magical hell Army in ranking of Kings
this kid will be forced to watch his
entire Kingdom crumble boji hears the
prince of the powerful boss Kingdom one
of the strongest Kingdoms in the land
led by boji's father this powerful giant
king boss born mute deaf and weak boji
is the black sheep of his family to say
the least and is considered a joke
within his kingdom No One Believes that
he has what it takes to become king but
is this belief that will cost them
everything he goes out one day to play
but bumps into a mysterious Thief
passing by him it stops boji and
threatens him for money then the
creature realizes that this kid is deaf
but can understand him by reading his
lips not having any money the creature
threatens boji for expensive clothes and
tells him to come back tomorrow to bring
more strangely enough boji smiles and
happily agrees over the next several
days boji comes back again and again to
meet with the thief and give him
expensive clothes and eventually the
thief introduces himself as kage
deciding to follow boji back to his
kingdom one day he sees everyone making
fun of the prince including the palace
guards boji then runs into his
stepmother Queen healing she gets pissed
off at him for being naked and showing
his crown jewels and complaints in front
of everyone that he has no right to be
king she thinks his younger brother is
more suitable and less stupid boji then
becomes sad and one of the Queen's
Entourage Damas tells boji that the
powerful King wants to speak with him he
goes to his room to change clothes and
kage follows it and there he finally
sees boji's strong smile flip into
sadness and shame boji then runs out of
the room to meet his father the king
Kake tries to follow him but gets lost
and runs into the man who will soon
torture him baby is shocked to see
kage's kind here and demands to know
what he's doing in the castle kage's
family belongs to a group of Assassins
and he threatens to kill kage unless he
confesses who he's planning to kill
right now Kake panics and tells him that
he's just there chilling with the prince
nothing to see here but Lord bieben
doesn't believe him and sharpens his
blade this is awful and now we're in
trouble and we didn't do anything this
is why I had to get away without any
violence I think we might have to cut
sweet little boji's ear off let me
explain Cog is a part of an ancient clan
of Assassins which means he's stuck out
like a sore thumb already and how he
acted was dumb as hell however he does
have a ton of powers that we could use
to get what we really want cash money
what money solves everything if I was
kage I wouldn't have been an idiot and I
would have realized that sneaking into a
fortified Castle which usually has
around 2 000 soldiers would have been
risky as hell it's a miracle he got to
boji's room without being discovered but
it also tells us that security is not
exactly the greatest in this Castle
cause he like snuck right in once
entering the prince's room I would have
stayed until Nightfall part of kage's
powers descends from assassins and he's
freaking tiny and he's able to blend in
and hide within the Shadows that is a
useful skill and castles are dark and
natural as hell and there's a ton
of Shadows and places that he can hide
in in terms of securing the bag trying
to steal the Castle's crown jewels would
not have worked since that would have
been under strict security or at least
you would hope but the thing that we
could steal is more of their expensive
Royal clothing that lies around modern
day Fabrics if rare enough have the
ability to be worth more than gold for
example a suit made a fukuna wool the
most expensive Fabric in the world would
cost around fifty thousand dollars
minimum and back in the old times
expensive fabric like these would have
been even more expensive this is why it
would actually make more sense to steal
their clothing instead of the jewels
that belong to the royal family before
leaving prince boji's room at night when
he was sleeping I would have grabbed one
of his sweet dolls their children
usually have and would have used it to
Club this kid's headed think of it like
clubbing a baby seal this would sort of
act as sort of a natural painkiller for
the poor kid in order for him to avoid
feeling what we're about to put him
through after that I would then stay
sneak out and head to the seamstress and
tailor rooms where all of the royal
fabric would have been stored after he
gathers all of it within his body which
is a part of his powers he'll be able to
sneak away because it's at night and
doing all of this in the night would
allow us to hide in the shadows and on
the off chance we do get caught we could
have revealed to them the princess cut
ear and could have bluffed that we
kidnapped him the shock from the air
would have bought us enough time to
escape before they would have figured
out that we were bluffing and cutting
boji's ear off wouldn't have done
anything to him anyways because as I
said he's deaf plus it would have gotten
him sympathy points from the ladies
growing up which means really he should
have thanked Us in the long run because
chicks love scars it's a win-win kakai
quickly distracts him and disappears
into the Shadows but he's not gonna get
away that easily as bieben sends out his
army of poisonous snakes to go after him
meanwhile boji enters his father's room
a legendary King who single-handedly
saved this Village from thousands of
monsters he coughs up blood and gives
Bosey for letting thieves steal his
clothes he tells Damas the best
swordsman in the Kingdom to train boji
to make him fit enough to be the Future
King and he tells boji to train hard so
he could be like his younger brother
Tomas takes boji out to train but sees
how weak he really is and it's pathetic
and just then boji's brother that little
snake Prince died up passes by and
challenges domas to a fight the two
battle it out the mosque gets shocked at
the prince's surprising skills telling
him that he's gotten better but Prince
Tita gets mad that he didn't win and
gets mad at Damas then boji steps in
front of Damas to challenge his brother
and the two prepare to Duke it out and a
crowd gathers around them including kage
nearby Prince died of charges at boji
but is stunned at how good his reflexes
are and he Dodges every freaking attack
of Dida with ease and even manages to
land hit after hit shocking The Village
but gradually people begin to get
annoyed with Prince boji because all he
does is avoid and keeps hitting on poor
Dida and everyone starts to think that
this fight is too one-sided all because
boji is so weak after the continual
humiliation of Dida Damas then steps in
and tells boji that his moves are not
very king-like and that he should take
the hits head on like a man confused
boji ends up getting very quickly
defeated by Prince Dinah but he doesn't
stop and beats the living crap out of
him until boji falls to the floor and
suddenly the fight is halted by this
man's spear a legendary bodyguard named
apis a man a lot more important to this
Kingdom's future than anyone realizes
with the fight over Prince Dida happily
goes frolicking back to his room that
little and he tells his magic
mirror that her prophecy is coming true
meanwhile boji's body and his shame get
carried into this room where he gets his
wounds treated kage finds him and sees
how pathetic the prince is he watches
boji unable to pick up a sword and he
begins to break down cry kage's eyes
light up with sadness and he goes up to
boji telling him that he shouldn't be
ashamed of who he is cause he's amazing
he shouldn't care what people say oji
then offers kage some more of his
expensive clothes but kagi tells him he
doesn't want anything from him anymore
and from now on he will stay by boji's
side no matter what happens the two
lonely Heroes become best friends
kage prepare to leave the room and he
tells boji that he'll be back to check
on him tomorrow but then he runs into
his new mortal enemy Lord demon and he
Corners him with snakes and quickly
kidnaps him the next day arrives and the
kingdom is dealt with the worst news of
all powerful King boss has just died
everyone holds their breath as they read
his official will and find out the worst
news of all the dead King wants boji to
become the new king shocking everyone
here why would he do this it's a
horrible decision and then suddenly a
terrifying Devil comes out of the king's
corpse and Towers over them with
Sinister intent and then it points to
little boji and begins to chuckle like a
psycho and then it disappears Prince
Dida runs back into his room and
complains to his magic mirror but the
magic mirror says that he will still be
king and she starts up her evil plans
the next day the crowning ceremony
begins and the rumors have already
spread that the dead King wants boji to
be king as everybody waits for the
inevitable to happen but then there's a
change of plans the royal family has
decided on their own that Prince dieda
should be the new King instead and
announce it to everybody this stuns boji
as he finds out thanks to the devil that
he saw yesterday his stepmother Queen
healing thinks King's boss's will cannot
be trusted because she let her inner
Court decide and get to vote on the new
King instead Damas votes for Prince Dida
and this causes boji to run out of the
castle in sadness alright this just took
a turn for the worst I'm gonna have to
kill the brother let me explain this
situation is more than just about
royalty because in this world kingdoms
are ranked by power level and the most
powerful Kings get a ton of treasure and
this means that even though our King is
already dead the stakes aren't over yet
because he needs to make sure that the
overall Integrity of the Kingdom sides
with him and is able to continue on to
the next king without any inner conflict
among his people because if that happens
then the Kingdom's overall ranking will
go down now getting to my first point
where we have to kill the brother us
being just alive poses a direct threat
to our younger brother's future power
and also since the people of the Kingdom
could one day side with us to fight
against Prince Dida and if you think
about it throughout history there's been
plenty of Royal siblings that have
murdered each other for the crown and it
seems to be no different that history
will repeat itself again and if we think
about the psychology of King dida's
character he's been groomed since birth
by our overprotective mother in the
hopes that he would be able to take care
of us Prince boji and also because
everybody thinks that we're useless this
combined with his hunger to be the
number one ranked King and his attitude
towards us as we have seen likely means
he thinks we're a huge nuisance to him
and a liability and we'll probably do
anything it takes to get rid of us and
this means that we need to strike first
now with all of this taken into account
it makes sense that we kill our younger
brother it really does because we just
saw a devil come out of our Daddy's
corpse it's very possible that we would
be able to blame the death of our
younger brother on some kind of curse or
evil demon this is what I would go to
see my younger brother at some point
over the next day and attempt to murder
him in his room we could use anything
really anything that's small enough in
diameter which means we will be able to
puncture his throat to very easy even
with our Prince boji level of strength
which is pathetic also the fact is is
that kage is within the kingdom and
worst case we could easily blame all of
this on him after all he loves us we
gave him all the Royal clothes in the
world that he could want which means we
can use him to put the blame all on kage
meanwhile kage continues to be tortured
but he's had enough of this then severs
his own body in order to escape running
out he thinks he's free but then runs
into his worst nightmare all over again
and he gets cornered by more poisonous
snakes and bieben steps off from the
shadows and asks kage one more time why
he's really here and this time no lies
and it's then kage swears that he's here
just because he's best Bros with a
prince and is there to help him and then
bibing goes to find Prince boji and
tells him that his friend kage has gone
off on a journey and will never come
back boji is devastated and is about to
have a mental breakdown but then he
thinks fast and realizes that since kage
promised him that he would never leave
he must still be with Lord bieben
somewhere in the castle elsewhere Lord
Babin gets sent to me to the new king
Dida who tells him that now that he is
King he must prepare for the Royal
ranking ceremony in this world kings are
ranked by their power by a mysterious
organization claiming to represent the
gods if King Dida wants to be the most
powerful King in all of the land he must
make him and his kingdom Strong by
killing all those who oppress his rule
including anyone who didn't vote for him
to be king thanks to his magic mirror
King didaida tells bibin that he knows
who didn't vote for him and orders him
to assassinate all of his unloyal
followers even worries that the magic
mirror is beginning to have too much
influence on King Dida but what does he
do he carries out his order without
question meanwhile boji explores the
castle and goes to meet one of bieben's
pets this giant snake and the snake
reveals that his master has captured
kage but he can't reveal anything else
boji looks at him with too much cuteness
and manages to convince the snake to
reveal a little bit more information ah
that little adorable Lord bieben
sent kage on an important Mission but
that's all he know hearing the same news
again Paving gets sad and depressed but
the giant snake tells him to stay strong
and that there are many people in the
Kingdom who do admire him nearby bieben
goes outside of the castle walls to try
and take down one of King daida's
unloyal followers the legendary Spearman
known as Opus the two quickly Clash
swords and combine Decades of
battle-harden's skill against each other
but opies manages to stab a bieben and
win the battle opies tells a dying
beeben that he will make boji King no
matter what back in the castle King Dida
deals with his mother Queen healing and
tells her that he fired all of those who
disagreed with him and asks if boji can
go off somewhere so he can be taken care
of somewhere else Queen gets shocked but
thinks fast and tells King Dada not to
worry about these small issues and tells
him to focus on ruling the kingdom
instead and in doing this she manages to
keep him off of boji's ass for now later
boji decides to leave the castle and
like a good stepson asks his stepmother
if he can go on an adventure and she
says it's too dangerous but boji decides
to do it anyways realizing that the
guards won't let him leave from the
front he decides to sneak out the back
through the window and begins tying bed
sheet after bed sheet together and he
prepares to scale down from this
terrifying height but then his
stepmother enters the room and rushes
over to go get him and boji squirms
while hanging on to his makeshift rope
but all that squirming causes the Rope
to loosen and boji comes crashing down
hard saved by his bag the stepmother
rushes over to help him but discovers
that he's critically injured and she
puts her hands together and uses her
magic to save him from the brink of
death boji then comes back to life just
as his stepmother passes out from using
too much energy and all the while no one
realizes that King died I watched all of
this from a
a few hours later the stepmother
realizes that she's been too hard on
boji ever since his younger brother was
born and reluctantly decides to let boji
go on his Adventure but tells him that
domas and this man hokaru will go with
him since they both know sign language
she warns them that they are only
allowed to go to her hometown and boji
gets super happy and plants a kiss on
his mother watching him leave she
suddenly gets a strange feeling that she
will never see him again meanwhile King
daida gets word that the most important
day of his life has finally arrived a
judge from the king's ranking
Association has arrived to determine
King dayada's ranking the king with the
first ranking will be able to pick one
item from the Divine treasure Vault his
magic mirror tells him that in order to
have any chance of ranking as the first
king he must murder his brother boji
slightly shocking King daida she reveals
that she has already made plans to have
his little brother assassinated because
one day the people may vote for him to
rule sad for his little brother but
obsessed with Power King daida agrees
she tells him that all he needs to do is
to now obtain his father's powers from
his body in order to become strong
enough to come first in the upcoming
ranking exam but King Dida gets annoyed
and insulted and tells her that he can
achieve greatness with his own power but
the magic mirror insists that she's
right but he doesn't listen to her King
Dida prepares for the first ranking test
and Duels against this powerful creature
but he ends up sucking balls so bad and
gets told by the judge that his King
ranking has now dropped to 90th Place if
he doesn't improve soon he will be the
worst ranked king of them all meanwhile
boji and his guards continue to travel
through the dangerous wildlands and they
reach this small town but boji ends up
getting lost and distracted how typical
by taking a nap near this Fountain when
he wakes up he gets discovered by
worried hokaro and they discover that
boji has had his bags stolen they
informed Tomas of the bad news and he
gets mad at hokaro telling him that the
queen had left a letter in boji's bag to
be delivered to her parents demos then
suspiciously asks hokaru if halobay
orders when the time comes he doesn't
understand what Damas means and he gets
told off by it mentions that it's not up
to them to question what the Royals do
whether it's right or wrong but hokaro
doesn't realize that poji is in terrible
danger the next day they leave this town
but come across boji's missing bag it's
strange but the crew keeps on going
avoiding all sorts of dangerous monsters
and traps except this one boji falls
into this hole and quickly avoids
getting stabbed alive unable to escape
he heads down this cave to find a way
out and comes across this stranger and
this man is on some crazy and he
asks boji to join him to perform a
dancing ritual with him and then they
proceed to shake shake shake it off and
after that the man feeds boji some food
and begins to talk about how ruthless
nature really is and in order to survive
others must die and then he starts
eyeballing boji to have him sacrificed
to the gods but boji quickly gets the
hell out of there jumping down this
cliff and he finally finds a worried
domas and hokaru damasten leads them to
this open area where they may camp for
the night and he whips out some food for
them to eat boji is about to dig in when
suddenly he gets hit with throwing lives
the game now on high alert realized that
that piece of meat saved boji's life and
then he watches some cute animals come
to steal the mid away and he realizes
that those knives belong to Lord bieben
the next day the three wake up and boji
and hokaro are horrified to see that the
cute animals that they saw earlier have
died from swallowing their nasty meat
and they realized that the meat that
they were about to eat last night must
have been poisoned the nervous group
quickly gets back on the road but gets
warned by damas that the next town they
pass will force them to go near the
gates to the underworld which means that
they must be careful Damas then mentions
that the town maintains its Prosperity
by capturing demons who try to escape
from hell and use their most powerful
Knights known as the order of the
underworld reaching this famous Town
Damas tells hokaro to go find them a
place to stay while he babysits boji
hokaro agrees and tells him that he'll
meet back up with them later but that
was his biggest mistake the most then
lures boji to go see the gates of hell
with him he tells boji go take a closer
look that's when he realizes that he's
been murdered I know I know the Betrayal
was insane but kind of predictable and
he kind of deserved it hear me out let
me explain listen boji is a pure good
innocent character but the problem is
he's too pure he's too nice he's too
naive and he's mute and deaf and only a
few people can communicate with him and
Tomas was one of them which if you think
about it explains why he was such a bad
teacher and on top of that we should
have spotted the red flags in advance
because boji hasn't learned from
him all these years because Damas has
refused to change his teaching ways
refused to encourage this new style that
boji discovered that actually allowed
him to succeed for once and that's why I
think over the years there was built up
resentment over boji's inability to
develop the physical strength to
actually fight the way that Damas wanted
him to and that probably created the
frustration and guilt over the years and
made it more cold and distant towards
boji and also this remember back when he
talked to hokaro about following orders
blindly and ignoring your moral compass
like where did that come from and this
means that it was clear way in advance
that Tomas had given up on boji because
well he was pathetic for too long Damas
was unable to teach him anything and the
closer he got to boji the more he
started to view him as a stray dog as
something pathetic as something
irritating a burden that he had to deal
with so when he finally was given the
opportunity to relieve himself of his
frustrations he took it and
unfortunately boji should never have
been so naive falling down into the
portal to Hell boji disappears into the
hellfires and Damas starts walking back
then begins to laugh and then cry and
begs Prince boji's Spirit to forgive him
he walks back but runs intokaru now
worried he asks where boji is but
quickly realizes that Damas has done
something terrible to him demos tells
him that it was his duty to kill Prince
boji hokaro gets enraged and attacks him
in anger but easily gets blocked by
Tomas who calls him a fool Damas sees
the pain in hokaru's eyes and quickly
feels bad so he lets hokaro cut his hand
before knocking him out regretting his
decisions he cuts off his hand in shame
later hokaro wakes up and gets told by
damas that King Dida ordered him to kill
Prince boji and that he had no choice
voice and being such a goodie two shoes
hokaro wants to report this to the queen
but Damas tells him that she doesn't
know what king Dida did and if either of
them go back they will be straight up
killed and possibly the queen as well
but hokaro stays stubborn and says that
he's going back no matter what back at
the castle King Dida has a dream of his
big brother saving him as Spirits all
around him tell him that Prince boji
Will Save The Kingdom suddenly wakes up
he realizes that he just had a dream and
becomes Furious he calls out to the
magic mirror and tells her what she
wants to hear that he wants to obtain
his father's strength and the magic
mirror Smiles elsewhere he wakes up at
the bottom of this hole it's boji and
he's alive he sits in shock and realizes
that someone saved him kage they
suddenly both cry in stupid stupid
levels of happiness and kage reveals
that Lord bieben assigned him to be
boji's secret bodyguard and he's the one
who saved boji from eating the poisonous
meat last night sensing that something
was wrong with it kage reveals that
bibin gave him a letter to the leader of
this underworld but he doesn't know
who's trying to have foji killed which
means that they must be on alert kage
tells him that according to bieben
someone deep within the underworld can
make boji stronger so they must go there
as soon as possible but then boji smells
something weird and they realize it's
poisonous gas they try to escape but
quickly pass out while someone
approaches them back at the castle King
Dida goes deep into the kingdom basement
along with the magic mirror and then he
sees two creepy people down there
waiting for him and he gets nervous but
the magic mirror says that these were
King boss's loyal servants and they will
help him gain power just like his father
entering this chamber he passes by
dozens of Frozen monsters along with his
father's corpse and she reveals that
they had him Frozen right after he died
and they will now use his corpse to make
King didaida powerful without being able
to get a word in King daida watches his
father fall into a giant medieval
blender and gets diced up into liquid
form adding some other ingredients into
this liquid the magic mirror tells King
daida that he must now drink this liquid
because this will make him obtain his
father's strength starts to have second
thoughts and mentions that he should
just work harder to get stronger but the
magic mirror says that the stakes are
too high she pressures him even harder
but King Dida gets angry and changes his
mind and states that he won't do it but
she tells him that he has no choice and
the two guards try to catch him but King
daida quickly uses his sick moves and
manages to knock them down he tells the
magic mirror that he wants to be the
number one ranked King by himself with
no help but that's when opies suddenly
enters the room with speed and precision
nearly killing king dieta thought the
magic mirror stops him telling him that
she needs him up here's his eyes light
up at the sound of the magic mirror's
voice and recognizes it it's lady
miranjo he tells her that he's here to
make Prince boji the new king according
to King boss's dying wish to fulfill his
will but lady maranta reveals that she
needs King daida for her plans and
Whispers something into office's ear and
it shocks King dieder Watches in horror
as his attitude suddenly changes and he
quickly knocks this kid out minutes
later King daida wakes up and is
horrified he's been tied up and he's
forced to witness lady a horse feed him
the potion while she Chuckles evenly she
then reveals her true plans and she
tells King daida that he's simply a
vessel and that she's on a mission to
bring back the true king of the land
years ago boss made a deal with the
devil in order to gain Incredible
strength but the devil borrowed the
strength of King boss's future bloodline
in order to make King boss's wish come
true and that is the reason that boji
was born weak because he had his power
stolen from him by his own father and
now lady miranjo plans to use dida's
body to bring the true king boss back
from the dead this is why I would have
tried to seduce the very same lady who
used to babysit us like we were in one
of those type of videos let me explain
King died of um until now never bothered
to look into the crazy signs that him
and his family were all going to die
listen if I was him winata brushed off
over our Daddy's death because if we
remember a freaking devil came out of
his body and somehow nobody bothered to
question that the moment a devil is
involved usually involves wanting youth
power fame or status and the fact that
our dad daddy a royal king was somehow
involved with the devil this should have
been a huge worry from everybody from
day one and clearly this was made very
obvious that something weird was going
on but even if we didn't know that the
real problem is lady maranjo she was
given to us as a gift by our daddy when
we were young and she basically watched
over us growing up which explains why we
were so close maybe a little too close
moving on now the most obvious sign that
something sinister was going on was Lady
maranzo's eagerness to help us to become
king because she was like way too
helpful because yeah while boji may be a
little weakling it's obvious that we had
no friends and this made it difficult
for us to gain outside perspective on
how suspicious this lady Miranda was
acting the whole time the lack of people
that weren't sucking up to him all the
time was King dieda's biggest weakness
because even if he didn't have friends
it makes no sense that he would have
never looked into finding out who lady
maranja was he just naively trusted her
like a freaking Fairy Godmother from one
of those movies because look at my weebs
if I grew up with a best friend it's
only natural that I would have wanted to
ask questions about their life and
discover who they are because I'm
curious I like this person I want to
know more about them and yeah sure she
could have lied to him I mean he could
have also asked his dad this whole time
or thousands of other people in the
Kingdom about who lady maranjo was or
how king boss came to possess her the
tale of how king boss was obsessed with
power and how he ran into lady miranger
is not a secret it's really not so that
means it could have easily come up at
some point if Dida had just bothered to
ask some questions especially from the
people that he surrounded himself with
listen at this point we need to use the
only move that we got and we need to try
to flirt or do something in order to
convince our glorified babysitter we
need to tell her that we'll do whatever
she wants then on the off chance that
she lowers her guard we then could have
used that to try to escape King tied up
panics and screams but suddenly starts
convulsing as the potion takes effect
and he now wakes up a changed man
meanwhile deep down in the Underworld
the mysterious Soldier drops boji and
kage into this room they wonder why they
didn't die in The Cursed gas and then
they discovered that these two are
already cursed this Soldier informs the
k tank that boji is a giant that got his
strength stolen from him and kage is
from the Shadow Clan and he had his
appearance altered by God once the two
finally wake up this King here tells
boji that he knows who he really is he
tells boji that he knows their kingdom
is going through some well kage
tells him that Lord bieben told him that
the king down here could help turn any
weak person into a proper King but kage
can't remember his name the king laughs
at them and introduces himself as Dasher
King of the underworld sanket ranking of
Kings this King tells him that he first
needs to know boji's power level before
he trains it by fighting one of his
powerful warriors the captain of the
order to the underworld boji happily
accepts The Challenge and kage nervously
sweats because he remembered what
happened last time and boji tried to
fight somebody didn't work out so great
so boji makes the first attack but
barely does anything it's pathetic this
Knight gets really confused akake
quickly interjects and says hey he's
really good at dodging and without
another word this Warrior quickly
attacks boji with all of his might and
that's when they see boji's true power
boji Dodges every move with Incredible
speed everybody is shocked except King
desha who says it's impossible to help
him without him having any strength at
all and declares that boji has no Talent
kage begs him to reconsider and shows
him the letter from Lord bieben
personally declaring the king Dasher
could help them this King takes one
quick look at the letter and laughs he
asks them if they read the letter but
kage says no King Dasher then rolls his
eyes and kicks them out of the castle
boji then begins to realize his
worthlessness begins to cry making kage
cry but just then one of the soldier
gives them their letter tells them that
according to this letter the man that
they are looking for isn't this King but
this king's younger way hotter brother
Lord desper the Knight tells him that
this man is very wise and will be able
to help him and then they bump pause
with kage and then wish him good luck
then they go to head off to find him
reaching his house they made Pretty Boy
desperate and give him Lord bieben's
letter about boji desperate tells him
that while boji may be weak he possesses
important qualities like courage because
that will be his Edge and then finally
boji has a decent anime training Arc
that finally begins he trains every day
while kage it's outside and wonders if
this man can really help boji and then
one day he hears a loud eruption coming
from boji's training room he rushes over
to check on them and catches a glimpse
of a weak boji splitting a rock and half
shocking kage back to the castle daida
now possessed by King boss's Spirit sits
on his throne lady maranjo then reveals
to him that because he already died His
Wish has been used up and now he is not
the most strongest person in the world
the new strongest person is his son
Prince boji but king boss doesn't react
to the news and then she drops another
bomb and says that they have to
assassinate Queen healing his wife even
shocking her evil Entourage but the king
keeps his poker face and lets lady
maranjo do whatever she wants nearby
hokaro finally returns and delivers the
terrible news to Queen healing telling
her that her son boji is dead shocking
and angering her she sentences hokaro to
death to strap him up and prepare to
execute him and just then Damas shows up
he's returned carrying hokaro he tries
to escape but he stopped by King daida
or so he thinks the mosque can tell King
died it seems different he attacks Damas
and he recognize is that this fighting
style is just like king boss king dieder
tells everybody to calm down and
announces that Prince boji is not to
dead and is currently training in the
Underworld where he is safe he then lets
off Damas and hokaro but he tells them
that they must leave this town right now
and before they go he quickly Whispers
something into dumas's ear and Lady
maranjo curiously tries to listen in
from a distance and Damas quickly leaves
with hokaru and reveals to him the king
boss is alive and has now possessed King
Dida he tells him the king boss just now
told him that there is an entrance
leading into the underworld underneath
this Castle they must go back there to
destroy the demons living there or else
Damas and hokaro then agreed to work
together meanwhile Queen healing
suspects that her son looks different
King dieder then Whispers again into
this guy's ear drusy and tells him to
protect the queen because uh well shit's
about to go down and he reveals to the
public that he's actually king boss back
from the dead well how's that for
honesty and he uses his super strength
to prove it Queen healing realizes now
what's going on desperately asks where
the real son is the king boss doesn't
know she passes out and worry later the
queen is resting in a room but her
bodyguard tells everyone there that
shit's about to go down and he suddenly
senses trouble outside he exits the room
and comes face to face with these demon
dog assassins they've been sent here to
kill the queen right now we are up
against demon dogs that have come from
the underworld which means that these
things are not to be messed with and the
fact that we are the only thing between
us and the queen was really a dumb
decision considering how bad the
situation is because up until now a
certified demon came out of your ex-dead
king and oh by the way now he's back so
that's a problem and now the real Dida
is missing and a little boji is
basically missing as well which means
that it was obvious even before this
that it's maybe time to leave the castle
like for starters the stupid queen and
the royals here should have come up with
a plan similar to how the real-life
evacuation plant that the British royal
family has they developed one during the
Cuban Missile Crisis at the time the
threat of nuclear warfare their
emergency plans developed to get the
Royals to safety which involved a
Detachment of 1 300 officers and the
fact that king boss here is one of the
top Kings ranked in the world means that
he likely had enough money to set all
this up or at least something similar
but him and even his wife were too
stupid to prepare for the worst I bet
they don't even have a panic room and
now the fact is that we got these demon
dogs that managed to show up right at
the Queen's door and avoided all 2000
guards inside of this castle that means
that someone either smuggled them in or
they came from somewhere nearby like oh
I don't know like the secret entrance
and this means that everything here is
probably compromised preparing for
battle the demon dogs attacked drucy one
by one and managed to damage his armor
he throws his shield at them but quickly
gets disarmed cornered he quickly rips
off his armor and turns into a six-pack
stuck gosh it's been a while since I've
been able to use that nickname anyways
the demons attack him again and again
and manage to make him bleed even more
he tries to punch one of them and slowly
gets ripped apart by these monsters
going into Last Stand mode he turns full
Savage and cuts and Slaughters everyone
there barely surviving until he
collapses from blood loss a little bit
later druzy wakes up and realizes that
Queen healing has saved his life and
tells him that she now has a new Mission
she will stand against king boss and get
her data back no matter what elsewhere
lady Marano sends the assassination
attempt has failed and tells king boss
that she must now go to the underworld
to get more demons king boss tries to
calm her down and tells her that she's
beautiful causing her to cry thank you
but she leaves anyways with her minions
to recruit people down in the depths of
hell all the while as king Boss watches
over the kingdom and when the coast is
clear Queen healing rushes over to talk
to king boss because she knows he was
involved in her assassination and
demands to know what lady maranto's goal
is and what he's done to king daida the
king boss says that he can't remember
she starts yelling out to Dada and
suddenly Dida hears her having just
woken up inside of king boss he thinks
he's now in prison inside of his own
body hearing his mother voice calling
out to him she barely just manages to
hear him and she uses her sorcery to
find the exact location and realizes
that her son is inside of king boss
frantic she tells drucy to get Dinah out
of there but no one else except her can
hear dida's voice out of options she
takes her knife out and prepares to kill
the king in order to release her son but
is stopped by druzy who tells her that
even if Dida is inside she can't harm
his physical body and he knocks around
king boss calmly voice is his concerns
for his wife to drusy he tells him that
next time he won't be able to protect
her if she acts out of line and if she
wants to stay alive she must leave the
kingdom now and wait for the right time
to come back to take down lady marancho
druzy then carries her out as her and
her most loyal followers escape the
kingdom back in the Underworld Lord
despar announces to kage that boji has
finally completed his hard training and
they prepare to celebrate with a feast
but kage wonders how boji is carrying a
big sword when he is so weak boji then
whips it out and kage gets concerned
because his weapon is thin as hell and
Jasper says that is part of his new
tactics for boji to work with boji has
no physical strength so he has to make
do with what he's got then kage finally
agrees Not To Doubt desper any longer
meanwhile back at the castle Lord bieben
is alive and he realizes that who is
rescued by his giant pet snake the snake
fills him in on what's going on Queen
healing's failed assassination attempt
and the magic mirror lady maranja is
headed into the underworld he also
informs him that he can sense that boji
has gone stronger bibim wonders if the
snake's prophecy Prince boji will avenge
become true and if Prince boji might
just become the one true king back in
the Underworld the three then hit up
this restaurant to start this
celebration but end up running into
three Thugs and these gangsters then
begin to make fun of kage and boji but
desperate tells them to keep their cool
and suddenly they make fun of desper and
he loses his and smacks this one
guy back he tells him that they can make
fun of his students but never insult his
gorgeous face and then he gets into a
brutal fist fight all because he's too
dang pretty that's sad anyways beauji
thinks he has a plan and joins in too
but gets punched in the face but then he
quickly gets back up revealing that
there's actually some toughness behind
that cuteness and he goes at them
desperate tells kage not to worry and
they watch boji quickly land a single
soft punch to this guy's chit and
nothing happens not because that's when
everything happens shocking kage in the
rest of the room this man collapses and
is knocked out cold but she quickly
knocks them out all with his soft
punches kage is blown away desperate
reveals to him that boji has been
training to find the weaknesses in
opponents because by taking advantage of
their weak points such as hitting them
on the chin causes them brain to get
shaken and causes a concussion and this
gang member gets pissed off and takes
out his sword and desper throws boji's
weapon the gang charges at him but boji
Dodges all of the attacks and quickly
disables his enemy making him fall to
the floor and kage thinks he's dead but
desperate tells him that because his
sword is so freaking thin and allows
boji to cut through the enemies without
hitting any important organs by hitting
the weak points of his enemies and then
cutting off their circulation to their
brain momentarily which will cause them
to pass out so now boji can now
basically defeat any enemy he encounters
without killing them impressing the
out of kage who thinks that desperate is
now the goat they leave the restaurant
as desperate leaves to take care of some
other business boji then reveals takage
that he learned his quick dodging move
from Lord bieben's giant pet snake that
he saved when he was younger this snake
is also the one who taught him how to
read lips and to not rely on sight kage
then tells boji that bibin warned him
that there was a huge conspiracy going
on in the kingdom and he told kage to
protect him because of this he asks boji
what their next move should be since he
completed his training boji thinks that
everyone he loved betrayed him including
his stepmother the queen feeling so kage
tries to cheer him up a little bit
because he's depressed and tells him to
remember the good in the world and that
they'll need courage to face the
darkness ahead and somehow this BS
motivation crab actually gets boji all
hyped up and so they take out quick five
minute cycle break and then he gets
hyped up again for the next part of
their adventure and then the two finally
decide what their next plans should be
they're gonna go back and save his
kingdom and his people but what do you
guys think about the video let us know
what you like about it and what you
didn't like about it don't forget to
like subscribe and leave a comment down
below and as always don't forget to
check out our how to be playlist